[Music]
all right everybody back for another
episode of asked mr. wonderful here
today with my recently acquired 1969
Telecaster telecasters are very
unforgiving guitars not that I want to
get sidetracked here but I just thought
maybe a couple of little riffs they've
got that kind of tinny twangy country
sound anyways let's get to the questions
and as always international some are
absolutely nuts
I mean you know what do you say this one
is from amber let's hear it
hi mr. wonderful my name is Amber and my
husband and I are huge fans of the
YouTube channel but I need your help
settling a huge argument that we're
having I've got to ask you I hope you'll
answer this for us would you rather hire
a dog or a cat to be your company's CEO
amber what are you nuts you know maybe
that maybe the question isn't that crazy
would I rather hire a dog or cat to be
my company CEO well you know maybe it's
not so nuts let me let me take a stab at
it because I want to talk about my
experiences with both species because if
I go back in time my first experience
with cats way back in college in my
second year got in my first serious
relationship I met this woman in film
class it was a nighttime class you know
the next thing in all Jed's a
millionaire and we eventually move in
together and it was my first sort of
living together relationship and all
that stuff and when we were moving in I
I met for the first time a chocolate
point Siamese cat now I didn't think
twice about it but there were two of
them
Sasha and Chad Oh so Sasha was the
female Chadha was the male
and you know okay we're you know we're
we're together it's our first night
we're sleeping together and you know
move well first time we were we were
living together sleeping together and at
about 5:00 in the morning Chado the male
sits on my head literally and starts Wow
and I'm thinking it's just a nightmare
what like what's going on here so sandy
that was my girlfriend's name says to me
Oh shadows hungry can you go and feed
him like it's 5:00 a.m. I said well why
don't we just leave the stuff in the
bowl for him oh no no he'll get to
fabulous meeting all the time what you
got to get up and feed him so that was
my first rude awakening shadow didn't
give a [ __ ] about me he just wanted to
be fed the cat was an arrogant bastard
it lit walked around the house doing
whatever it wanted sasha was a little
nicer but Chado every morning and always
like all of a sudden I'm the guy feeding
the cat so I'm not loving cats so much
and those are arrogant cats those
Siamese chocolate points those of you
that cat lovers probably know what I'm
talking about
they are the most selfish animals in the
world now apparently they were royalty
the ancient Egyptians covered them in
some of the carvings and paintings you
see you see these these Siamese
chocolate point cats but anyways so that
was the cat side on the other side of
the equation when I was young my dad
worked the United Nations and we kept
moving different countries and I ended
up in Addis Ababa which is the capital
of Ethiopia for two years I met Haley
Selassie there he had a very famous
collection of lions in his zoo that's us
my brother and I you know petting these
lions but my whole point was that the
foreigners all the the diplomats lived
in the same area of Addis Ababa sort of
a suburb and we'd hire guards or if the
houses were gated and this guard we
hired had a dog it was a mongrel it was
multi breed mix this dog was incredibly
intelligent it could listen to and and
and respond to five languages the local
language German free
English and Italian it was incredible
and it would be things like you know
lead the car in walk the car and make
sure there's nobody in the backyard I
mean the dog was like really smart and
I'm thinking if I have to have a dog as
a CEO that's the dog but there's a big
difference
that dog was working with humans acting
as a guard dog really intelligent
respondent's of commands in some ways
don't you want that from your CEO I
think so and certainly you want them to
be cognizant of their surroundings that
dog could so when I think about the big
debate between cats and dogs in the
context of leadership in the corporate
environment if I have to take it
seriously
I got a vote dog and there's some
examples lately of some pretty heavy
hitters in the corporate environment
check this guy out remember him yeah
yeah he he's sort of the mascot for a
multi-billion dollar corporation and not
doing too badly so amber you know after
all maybe you're not an idiot that was a
good question
I liked it sometimes you have to
flexibly have to think outside of the
box amber good for you let's take
another question yeah that was different
that's for sure all right what do we got
here let's have a look
no interesting interesting all right
let's listen to Alan
hello mr. wonderful out of the blue I'm
from Ireland the Netherlands and yes my
question is I got some depth 20,000 euro
20 and I feel like slayed by it you know
I just wanted just because of some
mistakes in my doing business and taking
risks you know and but I have my own
home and if I sell my own home then I
can make profits maybe forty thousand
then I could pay off my debt and I can
use the rest of the money to start all
over again in complete freedom and don't
making the same mistakes again where I
can invest in my in my new projects and
businesses and pay the rent up front for
six months so I have complete peace to
work on whatever excites me in the
moment what is your advice I don't
expect you to answer but okay Alan a lot
of questions in there and it's an
interesting one for all of us to talk
about because he's got a lot of issues
he's 20 thousand euros in the hole
that's about twenty four thousand
dollars approximately he owns a house
probably has a mortgage on it though and
he's thinking of selling his house to
get out of debt that's a tough one
because Alan let's go through a few of
these issues first of all real estate is
is not a very liquid asset so what if
you're gonna sell it that means you're
gonna go through all the brokerage and
tax fees associated with the sales so
let's say the brokerage fees are five or
six percent and then you're gonna have
to pay tax on the capital gain because
you say you're in the money so it's not
great but it is an option the twenty
thousand
I'm gonna guess you're probably paying
seven to ten percent interest on that
puppy a year so like that's worst case
two thousand euros just to service the
debt maybe it's you know a thousand
euros if it's five percent but anyways
it's bad because you have to go make
that money after tax to pay off that
interest so I don't like that so I think
we got to get out of debt here so
there's two options Alan you've got two
options here number one
you have to change your lifestyle
dramatically and somehow save over the
next 36 months 20,000 euros I don't know
what you're making but 20,000 if the
average salary in the Netherlands is
let's say I don't know 50,000 euros it's
really gonna be hard to do that you're
gonna have to save 20% it's not
impossible but it means you stop doing
cafe lattes you're not going out as much
maybe go out once a week I mean you're
really cutting back and you can do it
but you have to set a goal you have to
basically say I'm only gonna suffer like
that for 36 months that's why you can do
it and you have to stop buying crap
we've talked about buying crap you don't
need to buy crap you can definitely save
10 percent 20 is much harder but in this
case here's what I'm thinking and look
there's no perfect answer you got to get
out of debt it's gonna be one or two
ways you're gonna cut back on lifestyle
pay it down are you gonna sell this
house if you sell the house there's
something called imputed value in a home
in other words you have to live
somewhere so you either have to pay rent
or even if you don't have a mortgage the
opportunity loss of that capital because
you can't be guaranteed that a home is
gonna go up in value because we're at
the historic low interest rates and
Israel backup things like real estate
tend to not go up in value too much
because the cost of servicing it the
mortgage rates go higher so each month
they have to pay more to maintain it
it's an inverse relationship and for the
last 20 years interest rates have gone
down I'm thinking Alan in this case
maybe you want to sell the house wipe
out that debt save the other 20,000 in
the sense not saving it you're going to
invest it and now you're instead of
paying interest of 5% or a thousand
euros a year you're going to make a
thousand euros a year you're gonna have
to put it towards rent because you don't
have own a home anymore
but home ownership isn't a panacea it's
not perfect for everybody and so I'm
liking sell the house pay off the debt
and don't ever get in the hole like that
again don't make those mistakes you're
making you've got to really be fearful
of debt I but it's it's a really
interesting question
Alan brings up questions for all of us
we're all learning from this one I hate
that so much because of the service
in costs that's the problem so you know
what Alan sell the house it's cool you
can go back into real estate one day but
being out of debt it's like you said you
can sleep at night I mean a lot of bad
things that happen in life but going
bankrupt is horrific it puts so much
pressure it's unhealthy to be worrying
all the time about where your finances
are and debt is a very unhealthy thing
great question very unforgiving Kelly
[Music]
little basic chord riff there alright
another that I got to work on this
guitar it needs a setup I'm hearing it
rattling a little bit on the low e means
it's hitting the fret let's go back and
do another question here alright what do
we got
okay one more let's listen to oh I think
we did Allen already hold on going back
for Justin Justin ready for Justin
hi mr. wonderful my name is Justin and
I'd like to ask you about your opinions
on psychedelics I've heard that micro
dosing can be a competitive advantage in
the business space what are your
opinions on these naturally occurring
psychedelics such as psilocybin
mushrooms Thank You Justin micro dosing
LSD psilocybin mushrooms very
interesting question that's what I love
about ask mr. wonderful you never know
what you're gonna get it's like
chocolates you know that online you
never know what you're gonna get well
Justin brought up something very
interesting I'll tell you why full
disclosure I recently invested in a
company called mind med and it's doing
exactly that it's doing research on
micro dosing psychedelics to see if I
can cure opioid addiction alcoholism
depression and even discussions around
Alzheimer here's what happened in the
early 60s when LSD hit the scene people
were basically overdosing on it and
hallucinating like crazy and it became
quickly outlawed it became a Schedule
one narcotic and all the research at
that time that was being done slowed to
a halt some of the original samples are
still held by universities and
institutions it was actually invest
invented by Hoffman I think it was back
in the 50s
and it's recently the 60th or 70th
anniversary of the discovery of
Hoffman's LSD which was discovered in
Switzerland so those original doses are
still sitting in Switzerland so mine MIT
is actually setting up with scientists
to do medicinal research to turn these
into Pharma in other words fda-approved
drugs they will be micro dosing I think
this is a very interesting area because
when you think about the billions of
dollars lost from opioid addiction and
the tragedy that brings to families I
mean you get hooked on opioids often you
die I mean it's a really really bad
outcome and so alcoholism horrific for
families depression sometimes ends in
suicide
what if micro dosing could solve these
and so the only way to find out is to do
clinical trials which is what mine Ben's
going to do mine med is going to do so
I'm an investor it's a new investment
for me but I really you can probably you
know go online and look at all the
companies that are getting involved in
this space but Justin that's a very cool
question and so we should keep an open
mind to this this is not about drugging
yourself because micro dosing LSD is
being done right now a lot of it in the
West Coast with engineers and they're
getting you know I'm not endorsing it
because it's illegal but they're doing
it for a reason they're not
hallucinating they're sharper at work is
what they claim and so why not do some
research and find out if this actually
is true oops
[Music]
it's really tough this is a really tough
guitar to get see I'm screwing up
because I don't know the neck it's just
brand new guitar I've got a
[Music]
anyways a lot of work to do there let's
get another question here's Darren hi
mr. wonderful
I am currently 15 and in in the near
future in a few years I would like to
become a successful entrepreneur so is
there any advice which you can offer me
or suggest some things which I should do
to work towards the goal becoming a
successful entrepreneur on future Thank
You Darren very cool that you would be
15 and wanting to think about a career
as an entrepreneur I do have some advice
there and I think every entrepreneur
that enjoyed some success should give
back and you know it's the idea of karma
so I'm gonna give you some advice first
of all it is not an it's not an easy
road it's not it's not like working for
someone and I've said this many times
it's a journey not a destination
a lot of ups and downs a lot of
volatility in the career but to prepare
yourself for entrepreneurship there are
some great things you can do that really
have been done for generations over in
Europe you know we're not that old here
a couple hundred years old in North
America but in Europe they've had these
programs since the Middle Ages called
apprenticeships its equivalent to an
internship I guess but let's just let me
give you an example let's say you want
to be an entrepreneur in the jewelry
industry or the watch industry and you
want to start your own company one day
well you can go and work from the age of
16 years old for a great Mazal house
like Cartier if you're talented they
will actually train you for up to 10
years they they've got you know special
houses maisons where they take you into
the mountains and you go to school at
night and then you might go to during
the day be trained in in the making and
the craftsmanship of creating
one-of-a-kind art pieces of jewelry I
mean that's an extreme example Nestle
for example a food company in
Switzerland they have apprenticeship
programs you go work there
for three years you actually get paid
while you're going to school and or you
know after school and you work for three
years as a low-paid apprentice and you
learn the craft you're not an
entrepreneur at that point but you're
learning the ways of business and you're
learning the ways of the industry that
interests you and so my whole message
about this is if you're 15 years old you
know the old adage go set up a lemonade
stand that's [ __ ] you have to learn
about the ways of business and how it
all works and so it's better to be
inside a business and learning and then
once you've got your chops you check out
a Dodge and you start up on your own and
you know what's really cool about that
program and why it works here in North
America works anywhere people get to
know you and if they like you they'll
actually maybe fund your startup buy
from your startup have a relationship
with your startup because you came out
of that industry that's my advice is to
find out that the hardest thing to do
when you're 15 is to kind of figure out
what is that I want to do because you
don't know so if you're if you're
interested in entrepreneurship and
business one good thing is to go into
even in high schools now in Florida for
example have business classes in high
school which is great you learn about
financial literacy about setting up a
business about accounting bookkeeping I
really like that it would be great if
you went into college for business
because you're gonna learn a lot that
you're gonna meet a lot of people but
not everybody goes to college and you
don't it's not we represent for success
but certainly if you're gonna go to high
school and finish that off take a class
in accounting take something that has
anything to do with numbers in business
and give yourself an upper and upper
chance and then if any or any you know
an upper hand or at least a higher
probability of success you know I come
to think of it it's at fifteen years old
if you know you want to do that you're
probably gonna do okay and remember this
above all you will have some failures I
guarantee it you're gonna have failures
and don't let that set you back I for
every success I've had I probably had
two failures that's just the nature of
entrepreneurship you only need one big
success and you'll set yourself free
you know it's not about the pursuit of
money it's not the greed of cash it's
the pursuit of personal freedom to sit
around and try and learn a new guitar
whoa that's so tinny I got a lot of work
to do here I like that question anyways
you know I think about it you have to
have fun you got to do this kind of
stuff but the whole idea of asked mr.
wonderful is the sharing of these ideas
you may not agree with everything I say
but it's just I'm giving you my download
from my experience and what I've learned
some of these things are really
important but if you really want to set
yourself free
maybe that's the theme of this week's
episode because there's have many
questions about businesses and pursuing
entrepreneurship you got to take risk
and sometimes it's not comfortable and
if you can't handle that discomfort you
will fail so think about that you have
to be able to sustain the fear of
failure you have to be able to hold that
and use it as a motivational force
because believe me there will be nights
when you think I'm wiped out I'm dead
but let that be the motivator for you
take from that and don't let it take you
down you have to use it as a competitive
weapon fear of failure can really really
be useful
anyways think about that when I'll see
you next episode take care of my friends
[Music]
that was a you-know-who riff remember
that
[Music]
you
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
till next week